welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is joy Pacha Wow a professor at the
Center for historical studies at JNU in
New Delhi she's currently at the program
and agrarian studies at the Macmillan
Centre on a Fulbright narrow academic
excellence fellowship her research
interests include the history of
Christianity in India and the
socio-cultural history of North East
India today we'll talk with professor
Tetsuo about her book being Mizzou
identity and belonging in northeast
India
welcome professor thank you thank you
let's start with your book tell us about
it well as the title suggests the book
is about people group in northeast India
called Mizzou and the northeastern India
is constitutes eight states and the
missile's usually inhabit the state of
Missouri so these are people groups that
are identified as scheduled tribes by
the Indian Constitution or alternatively
can also be called as indigenous people
groups so the bazaar is a general term
for a group of tribes that inhabit the
region and surrounding areas including
Burma and so the book is essentially
traces how they constitute themselves
how they understand themselves and how
in history they have grown to be this
people group known as the middle so the
book essentially talks about that and
yeah look at the history of the people
okay and what drew you to this traffic
well firstly I am from the region
surrounding the state so that's one of
the interest groups and that also you
know enables research but also because
northeast India as a whole is a region
that is relatively on
known to the larger world but also to
India you know people really understand
the region as separate people groups as
separate identities even if they know
the region it's more or less like as a
region but they do not know the
specifics of the region so so it's it's
a means of bringing out the region to
the larger public as well and there's
not much literature in English on the
region as a whole as well so that's one
of the reasons I mean those are some
other event and if there's a fascinating
history as well and a fascinating story
or four people so that's the reason why
I wanted to look at and study the region
okay and how are you doing the research
what's the method ology well I'm
essentially a historian by training but
I mean if video studying indigenous
groups like that you have to sort of
understand the sort of the methodology
of anthropology as well there's
basically historical anthropology and so
I look at a lot of archives
I mean records British records and
things like that so it's a lot of
archival work as well as talking to
people and ethnographic research in that
sense yeah
okay so the Mizzou are in the it's
almost kind of a how big of a territory
would you call it in terms of home as it
relates to India I mean it's very small
and the continent in India's is pretty
large well you know Mizoram by itself is
about twenty-one thousand square
kilometres I'm not sure how much data
yeah but yes it's about 21 and the
population is about a million so oh yeah
just yeah the density of the population
about fifty people can experience an
intention would I be correct in saying
it's kind of like a peninsula off of off
of the mainland yeah what's surrounding
what are the countries around it as
Bangladesh founded Asia's to the east
okay so the northeast of the region has
eight states and Mizoram is one of the
states of the Northeast right okay
Mizoram is surrounded by Bangladesh to
the east and Burma to the west yes oh
and of course to the South Bangladesh as
well so and it's only connected to the
rest of India and the North here okay so
how does mainland and gave you the
Northeast you had mentioned that you
know some you know aren't even very
familiar with it
are there any other views that are held
predominant layer yeah well in India at
the moment there's a lot of debate about
regarding racism with with regard to
people of the Northeast so there is you
know if you look at student groups who
come to the took what is referred to as
mainland India by I mean of course
that's the subcontinent is referred to
as mainland India although it doesn't
really signify that but anyway so when a
lot of students come into the region
comes to mainland India they suffer a
lot of racism and you know people do not
give them houses to rent or or you know
just the other day there was a student
from another state and notice India who
was beaten up by the landlord and things
like that so there is a lot of racism
that that the people of the region have
to suffer and what does that come from
do you think well mm-hmm that are being
different just being different at one
level and also you know it could stem
from various things in recent times yeah
it's basically not knowing the region I
think that would be and also not knowing
the region as being a part of India as
well and you know you know when it goes
when it when we when we go to the waters
known as the mainland people think
you're from you know foreign countries
and and usually the people of the region
don't like that you know if you are
called the Chinese or when the rest of
the country is your own country right so
so things like that so people have to
suffer a lot of racism as well in many
forms where there is an education and
then also you know because you know the
word tribe in India
has different connotations and people in
the region are referred to as stripes so
you know tribe has its own sort of set
of baggages that people have to overcome
as well so I think so I think it's a lot
of little things again with my mom and
do the Mizzou look very physically do
they look very different from those on
mainland you know yeah well you know
most of the region speaks a different
language group which is tibeto-burman of
course there are other language groups
as well like the austroasiatic and
indo-european as well but the main
predominant people groups you could say
speak to better Berman so which which
also means that as people people you
know in in the physiognomy in a way
people are much more closer to Southeast
Asia than they are to the Indian
subcontinent as it were so so in terms
of difference definitely physically
there is a lot of difference yeah okay
what about religion this how does
religion play a role and the Meisel you
know so most well almost all ethnic
methods are Christian so and these were
the result of 19 the 20th century
conversions within a matter of 50 60
years the entire people group became
Christian so even prior to the adoption
of Christianity the people as a region
identified themselves on the basis of
religion on their basis of their sort of
local beliefs so if a person wanted to
change his or her tribe there was a
there was a there was a sort of ritual
by which you could convert you could
adopt another tribe and if you wanted to
adopt another tribe you had to adopt the
sort of religion of the other tribe you
know so in a way who you were was
dependent upon the religion that you
adopted okay so so having adopted
Christianity as a people group I think
it becomes very important themselves
vacation who you are is so you will
rarely find you know missiles who are
non-christian because if you are a
non-christian you cannot be measured in
a way that's the way things are at the
moment at least yeah okay and did you
look at any examples of that actually
happening with a specific person who
decided they did not believe in in that
religion any longer and and how the
interaction with the rest of the tribe
changed
um so curved at the movement you will
not find people who well who don't
associate themselves with Christianity
you know even if they are not mainline
church groups they are usually you know
belong to sort of factions of
Christianity so there are different
kinds of denominations of Christianity
but most are mostly all our Christian
right so so you wouldn't find that today
but in the past of course in history you
know the adoption was not very simple it
was not straightforward so people will
for the Christians were you know thrown
out of villages and and they had to
create their own villages so there was a
lot of tension in the past in the
adoption of Christianity in order but
currently at the moment
apart from very very small sort of
groups that constitute themselves
differently
you would rarely find anyone who's not a
Christian okay okay because I was just
looking for instance Scientology for
instance here if if you no longer
believe in Scientology you basically
have to leave that all behind and and
leave but that's not the instance with
some yuzu yeah yeah I mean people really
sort of I don't know move forward of
Christianity in a way if they've moved
into Christianity people mostly people
have stopped at being Christian they
haven't moved to any other thing okay I
was at the moment is nice of classify I
don't know how things will change in the
next few years or what yeah
yeah so what are some of your findings
in your book well and how long have you
been studying the Mizzou well um the
missile has been working on them since
about Maine as really looking at their
history for the past ten years or so and
so the book is so I think interesting in
the sense that you know the missiles
were not one tried as I was saying
earlier they constitute different tribes
and in fact at a point of time would
have had different languages but now
more or less they within the state of
Missouri they consider themselves
missile and they speak the missile
language but the same tribes that
constitute the missile are are
constitute themselves differently in
other regions like in Burma they would
consider themselves different tribes in
the neighboring state of money pool they
would consider themselves as the
constitutive tribes whereas in Missouri
they've all come together as missile
generally speaking huh so so the book
essentially traces the history of that
sort of homogenization in a way but the
reason why I look at the creation of
this identity is because even as I was
studying for the society I found that
you know debt and debt practices were
important way of bringing two people
together and let's talk about that yeah
yes so for instance in the capital city
of eyes all you would have you know well
let's first of all let me say that the
fit you know it's a really homogeneous
society right but then you would have
sort of people coming from other regions
as well
but then you find that even people who
come from other regions tend to
constitute themselves as mizzle yeah
tend to in know in course of time you
know identify them
so if you have sort of a missile woman
who's married a person from mainland
India very often the person from
mainland India is incorporated as a
missile in time and do they also
self-identify as missile oh you know if
they themselves don't even if they don't
in a way I mean they it would be very
difficult for them to identify
self-identified and services their
children often take up their mothers you
know so even though our the missile
society is a patrilineal society the
children of you know of missile women
and non-nasal person would identify
themselves as missiles so you know it's
a very sort of absorbs people in in
Norway and you find out how I mean how
does one see that and that is where I
come the debt and debt practices because
all those who are considered mizo
usually will be buried in in the
locality graveyard or symmetry and given
the rituals of a missile you know so
even if you are technically an on
missile if you have been adopted as a
little then you have that sense of and
people want to be buried in their local
graveyard or local symmetry they don't
want to be buried elsewhere so if a
person dies saying Delhi the body is
flown back and has to be buried in the
locality graveyard so in a way the
burial in the graveyard
sort of fulfills his identity as a
missile as well you know it completes
his his journey as being a little so you
know for instance if a person is buried
elsewhere then you know people think of
the family as being you know as if you
very sad for the family of the person
who's had for some reason to be buried
ever you know so the idea in the phrase
that is used is the burial of the head
you know I mean the head is a metonym
for the whole body so they say in this
pool which means that so-and-so had to
bury the
head of their son or their daughter in
another place and so it's worth grieving
about because they could not bring the
body back into the locality gradient so
how did this you know in the past this
was not the case
you know this identification because the
missiles were generally migrant workers
or warriors in a way the people migrated
from place to be so there was the
territory was not sacred in a way but
it's only a recent sort of 20th century
phenomenon where where the region
becomes a territory becomes sacred and
people have to be buried in a particular
look at it wasn't so in the past so what
is tracing how that happens how there is
sort of a territory a territorial
ization of identity how does that take
place and it has a lot to do with you
know the arrival of colonialism the
arrival of Christianity and the pinning
over people to a territory with people
were always on the move you know the
history of musa moses is an arrival from
further east
further east meeting burma and and even
beyond northern burma or northern
Myanmar and even beyond that so people
trace the origins to to China sometimes
and they say that there were these waves
or migrations that occurred in the past
and and so they were in what is known as
miserable today at the time of the
arrival of the British and the British
forbid that moving around and so that
they became tied to a particular tech
history and so the territorial ization
of them leads to characterization of
them as a people even in terms of death
you know so that's how I sort of trace
it backwards in a way and the other side
a simple thing do we have our there are
people migrating from Burma and China
and those parts you mentioned to
northeast India today or has that pretty
much stopped well people are anything
especially at the time of of the
dictatorship in Burma a lot of people
did move in
to Mizoram the neighboring state in
Burma for Mizoram is the chin state so a
lot of people would move into two to the
Mizoram during that period of time but I
think it's much less now with demography
coming in and more opportunities but
also because of you know modern-day
technology a lot of the Qin migrated not
to Mizoram but to the u.s. so that's
that's a that's yeah so there are lots
of Qin Canon t3i
is there any chance since it doesn't
seem like many are migrating to that
part and some are actually you know
leaving to go in other places that the
Mizzou will die out is that ever a
concern I don't think so I mean at the
moment because you know even though they
they called tribal law scheduled tribes
and think of it the missiles have the
highest rate of education in the country
as a state highest or second highest
they usually have that points it's a
very sort of literate society it's it's
not so developed in terms of economy but
in terms of the economy because it's
really mountainous region the highest
peak is about seven thousand feet or
something of that sort and so so it's a
very mountainous region as well so so
but people are doing well because of the
high literary standards compared to the
rest of the country so I don't think
there is okay I had any danger of the
people dying and also you know because
as I was saying Christianity is a very
important part of people's social life
and so people are extremely and because
of the trishy as well there is sort of
you know the high levels of literacy
high levels of the kricher local the
christianism addresses in fact a very
thriving culture in that sense you know
okay and as I was saying earlier even if
middle women marry non deserves
they children are always incorporated as
missiles as well
I am appoint so what you conclude in
your book well the conclusion of courses
is to talk about well you know the
Constitution of identity how that
happens historically and of course you
know that identities are constructed you
know there might be a primordial notion
of how people understand themselves but
people build on that historically in
order to be able to understand order to
be able to understand themselves so
identities are usually a created
identity you know the middle identity
name morph into something else in future
you never know but and it made the
identity to date the way they see it may
not be something that people in the past
practiced or understood so it may morph
into something else so this is always a
sort of a process of construction is
yeah so that's basically what talks
about very interesting thank you for
being here with us today thank you thank
you very much here for more information
about professor patois and her research
please visit our website at macmillan
report yelled at edu be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Eddie
Macmillan Centre for International and
area studies at Yale
[Music]